[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back y'all our next guest is a
New York Times bestselling author with
more than a dozen books to his name
including when I was the greatest all-
American boys and long way down stamped
racism anti-racism and you now he's
debuting his very first children's book
called there was a party for Langston
please everybody Welcome Jason
[Applause]
Reynolds
[Music]
all right I have to lead with this
because I mean novels poetry non-fiction
this is usually your field right this is
this is new for you picture books right
yes yes yes very new for me what made
you want to do it well I mean first of
all because there are children that age
right I I specialize primarily in young
people and uh that goes from 18 19 all
the way now to the youngest of the lot
which are which are the babies and it's
been amazing for me I know it's a
different way right what's the process
how is it different for it's an
incredible challenge you've done this
right you know I I honestly when I I was
like this should be easy oh my God yeah
this is what every everybody is like oh
no man this is like the easiest way all
you got it's like 50 words and I'm like
yeah it's like 50 words oh my God it's
it's harder it's it's much and to keep
them captivated to write something like
and and you don't always know what the
thing will be that will keep them
captivated I think with novels there's
narrative Arc there's all kind of
structure and
analyses and all this other stuff you
can do right but with this you get just
a few words to try to figure out how to
hit a particular pulse with a population
of people that you don't always quite
understand absolutely so it's it's
complicated yeah so why linkston Hughes
why Langston Hughes you know I to me um
Langston Hughes is uh one of the most
important literary luminaries I think
that he birthed multiple generations of
writers and in this case specifically
black writers a lot of us came up
studying The Works of a man whose work
seemed to be uh at eye level though
truthfully was far more sophisticated
far more sophisticated than I think we
give credit to it's it's the idea that
there's a vast difference between that
which is easy and that which is simple
right just because a thing reads as easy
does not mean it was simply made it
usually means the opposite yeah right
that it was very difficult to make a
thing that feels and reads and sounds
easy and Langston Hughes was the master
of that yeah to make it look it's not oh
my gosh it's like a magician like yeah
well so the book um was inspired by this
picture right yes yes I love this
picture am so much joy so muchy so much
pride so much going on in this why this
picture for you you know I mean first of
all the picture in of itself is amazing
to see these two icons Maya Angelou am
Mary Baraka so we all know who Maya
Angel was
and and um and Amir Barack
was uh one of the leaders of the Black
Arts Movement a very important figure in
poetry specifically through the 1960s
and70s but for a lot of Us coming up he
was sort of like a like a like a OG
figure somebody that we could look to as
a hero so to see this Photograph and to
see our two Heroes two of Our Heroes
dancing and to know that they were
dancing at the Shamburg library right up
town yeah um and they were dancing on a
cosmogram on the floor in the Shamburg
and underneath that floor that piece of
floor were uh an our the ashes of
Langston Hughes um they're buried under
that floor so when we talk about when we
talk about standing on the shoulders of
giants yeah we're talking about people
literally doing so and I would argue
they're doing it better than most
because they're choosing not just to
stand but to dance yeah right and so
there's something to that continue to
inspire absolutely what's the point of
standing if you're not going to do
something make you yeah oh my gosh you
are great with words my friend yeah oh
my God gosh and your tone I'm like okay
uh Jason's newest book I'm sold Jason's
newest book is called there was a party
for Langston and everyone in the
audience is going home with a
[Applause]
[Music]
copy thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home oh